[Music]
this is the National Ignition facility
at Lawrence Livermore National
Laboratory in Northern California it's a
multi-billion dollar facility funded by
the Department of Energy that's designed
to stimulate the conditions inside a
nuclear explosion allowing scientists to
maintain the nuclear weapons stockpile
without detonating an weapon but it
might have equally important civilian
benefit hydrogen bombs work on the same
principle as our Sun
they both obtain their power through
fusion a tremendous heat and pressure
hydrogen atoms fuse together into helium
and release a huge amount of energy
without the toxic leftovers of the
fission nuclear power plant tapping into
that clean energy source has been a
longtime hope society and the National
Ignition facility could provide
physicists who know how to finally do it
and all it takes is one hundred ninety
two of the world's most powerful lasers
amped up to incredible energy before
being focused on to a target about the
size of a pencil eraser
[Music]
we're here at Lawrence Livermore
National Laboratory with Edie Moses
director of the National Ignition
facility and can you tell us a little
about the facility yeah this is the
world's largest laser it's the world's
largest laser in terms of the energy it
puts out about a hundred times more than
any other laser that has ever been built
on earth well there are three basic
goals of NIMH you know the first is a
strategic national security second basic
science of the cosmos the third is the
long pole in the tent and probably the
one most interesting to the future of
our society could we get clean carbon
free limitless energy that's called
fusion energy this facility now is two
years away from demonstrating
thermonuclear burn in the laboratory or
fusion and what we're going to be doing
is putting together special types of
hydrogen deuterium and tritium at very
high temperatures
and very high pressures for a short time
and getting that energy has Einstein
told us equals mc-squared
if you look at behind me right now this
is the target chamber where all that
happens we have all these lasers which
creates all the energy but we bring it
all into this target chamber to a very
small spot sort of the size of a tylenol
capsule you know and focus it down to
something about the size of your hair
and using that really high-intensity
light we can create the conditions that
are of interest so here we're in a
situation where we can take astrophysics
and instead of doing that through
telescopes watching things that happened
millions or billions of years ago we
could as schedule a a Sun or solar event
or a supernova let's say next April on
April 23rd it's 4:00 in the afternoon
bring all your Diagnostics so that's
something very exciting some people
think this is a light machine I think of
it as a data machine writes to
scientific data machine finally what we
put out our ones and zeros that
scientists or other people can use to
understand what happened during a shot
and the way we do that is we have around
35 special Diagnostics a rain around a
target like porcupine quills
that look at the optical light that
comes out x-ray light neutrons and other
characteristics of how the target is
acting by doing that we can figure out
what happened whether it agrees with our
codes you know and understand how to
design further shots over this last you
know 48 years now people have been
increasing their understanding what has
to be done that technology has come
along and this laser facility was
designed to do ignition this facility is
around 700,000 square feet and it costs
us around 2.2 billion dollars to build
this facility we also did around a
billion dollars of research and
development on the way to doing it a lot
of experiments have been done on the way
to this there's a lot of confidence that
what we have here is built to get the
answer our goal is 2010 to do our first
in campaigns
[Music]
you